WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE SO
WE CAN START HERE IN SOME BILLS.
HE AND WE HAVE A TOTAL OF NINETY
BILLS TODAY WITH THE A. B. TWO
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- ONE
BEING PULLED FROM THE AGENDA.
WE HAVE EIGHT ITEMS ON THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE
ITEMS INCLUDE.
ITEM -- ONE SB FOUR THIRTY TWO
NIELSEN ITEM THREE AB TWO THIRTY
BRO.
ITEM SEVEN AB. EIGHT SIXTY NINE
CUNNINGHAM -- ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
MULLIN ELEVEN NINETY NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE VETS
COMMITTEE. FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR
GRAY AND SIXTEEN FIFTY COOLEY --
SO WITH THAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD YOU ARE.
ALL IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS -- IS.
MY HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
NINE SEVENTY SIX SO.
I LIKE TO START OFF BY --
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE THE A I
COMMISSION TO ADOPT GUIDING
PRINCIPLES DELAYED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YEAR
REQUIRED THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
BE SUBMITTED TO ANNUALLY.
AND ALSO AT A SUNSET DATE AS
WELL AS ADDING COAUTHORS SO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR A AYE
HAS AN INCREDIBLE ABILITY TO
CREATE A GLOBAL.
PARADIGM SHIFT OUT MAY PROPEL
SOCIETY INTO AN AUTOMATION H.
AND PROPOSE UNIQUE SOLUTIONS TO
SOME OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST.
PROBLEMS ARE ITS APPLICATION MAY
SOON BECOME IMMERSED IN EVERY
MAJOR AREA OF OUR WORK AND
PERSONALIZE SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION COMMUNICATIONS.
HEALTH CARE ALL EDUCATION
CRIMINAL JUSTICE JUST TO NAME A
FEW ALL THIS EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
PRESENTS OPPORTUNITIES IT ALSO
COMES WITH ITS OWN CHALLENGES
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY.
DISPLACING WORKERS ALSO PRIVACY
OR REINFORCING INSTITUTIONAL
BIASES.
AMONG OTHERS -- THESE LEGAL AND
ETHICAL CHALLENGES WILL REQUIRE
INVOLVEMENT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS -- TO ADDRESS AS A
RESULT WE TO LEGISLATORS MUST
FACILITATE DOT DIALOGUE TO FIND
A BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING OF
STATE'S POPULATION.
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY AT DRIVING
INNOVATION AND PRODUCTIVITY'S AS
A LEADER IN THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE SO THE BILL IS
INTENDED. TO BEGIN THOSE.
CONVERSATIONS BY SALVAGING THE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES COMMISSION.
TO GATHER INPUT ON HOW OFFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND DATA SCIENCE
COULD BE USED TO IMPROVE STATE
SERVICES -- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF BILL IS A
TRULY SAID THE THE GONZALEZ WITH
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I WILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS HE
SAID THEY GONZALEZ AND I'M A
RESEARCH ANALYST FILTER FOR
COMMISSION HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE SEVENTY SIX THE COMMISSION
IS AN INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
RECOMMENDING WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT.
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
EMBARKED ON AN ELEVENTH MONTH
STUDY. TO UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
STATE IS PREPARING FOR THE USE
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT A I
CAN PROVIDE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES
LAST FALL THE COMMISSION
RELEASED ITS REPORT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THE ROADMAP FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
ADDITIONAL COPIES OF THE REPORT.
OUR REVIEW INCLUDED A PUBLIC
HEARING AND ADVISORY MEETINGS
AND WAS INFORMED BY
CONVERSATIONS WITH NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS.
THE WORST STUDY THE COMMISSION
IDENTIFIED MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO
USE A AYE LET ME STATE JUST TWO
EXAMPLES.
A I MIGHT HELP EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS PREDICT WHEN AND
WHERE FIRES ARE LIKELY TO OCCUR.
OR A I MIGHT HELP EDUCATORS
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES.
AND WHILE CALIFORNIA C.
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE STRIDES TO
IMPROVE OPERATIONS AND SERVICES
EMPLOYING MODERN TECHNOLOGY IT
IS INCREDIBLY UNDER PREPARED TO
RESPOND AND ADAPT. TO THE SPEED
WITH WHICH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS CHANGING OUR
WORLD.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
IN THE WORLD AND A TECHNOLOGICAL
POWERHOUSE BUT THE COMMISSION
FOUND.
THAT A STRATEGIC PLANNING VOID
EXISTS THE GOVERNMENT AROUND
SEIZING THE OPPORTUNITIES OF A
AYE.
OUR REPORT ISSUE TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
THE VISION OF COORDINATION TO
COVERED FOR THE FUTURE.
AMONG THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
COMMISSION CALLS FOR THE
CREATION OF AN EXPERT COMMISSION
FROM DIVERSE SECTORS TO DEVELOP
AND INCORPORATE A AYE RELATED
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR
CRITICAL STATE SERVICES.
AB NINE SEVENTY SIX SHARES THE
COMMISSION'S GOALS BY
ESTABLISHING THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND STATE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES COMMISSION.
THE LITTER LOOKED A LITTLE WHO
WERE COMMISSION SUPPORTS THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE ABOUT I'M HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- WE DO TO
OBVIOUSLY DO NOT HAVE THE FORM
IS THIS TIME SO WILL VOTE ON IT
LATER BUT IT WITH YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CLOTHES STRONG CLOSE THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. FORTY
SEVEN MEMBER GOOD MORNING
SENATORS HOW ARE YOU TODAY.
WELL MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NOTED
ON PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS IS
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS ON I THINK THE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE
ANY STATE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
EXCEEDS A BILLION DOLLARS TO
FORM AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
DEVELOPING USE RISK MANAGEMENT
PLANS THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THE PROJECT IS OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WOULD BE REQUIRED. TO
COMPLY WITH OPEN MEETING LAWS
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN THE OVERSIGHT PROCESS AND
ENSURE THAT LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS ARE BEING DELIVERED.
ON TIME AND ON BUDGET OUR
SUBCLASS FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT HEAD
SENATORS RICHARD MARCUSSEN FOR
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AS YOU MAY KNOW WITH THE AC
RELEASE RELEASE THERE ARE TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT CARD SHOWING
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRADES DROPPING --
FROM C. TO C. MINUS OBVIOUSLY
MORE SPENDING IS IMPORTANT BUT
IT NEEDS TO BE SPENT
APPROPRIATELY IN A RESILIENT IN
A SUSTAINABLE WAY.
OF CREATING THE OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENT FOR MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
INSURERS THAT TAXPAYERS AND
CITIZENS ARE GETTING THE BEST
VALUE FOR THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLAR WE SUPPORT IT STRONGLY.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE YOU THAT WAS A NICE
CLOTHES AS WELL.
VOTE DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS WELL
HE'S GOT ANSWERS.
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BOB SUPPORT OF THE BILL I AM I
BELIEVE.
GREATER TRANSPARENCY LISA
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY I IF I
READ CORRECTLY I TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ARE EXCLUDED AND IF SO
WHAT'S IT IS ANOTHER MECHANISM
THERE WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE FOR
THAT.
YOU ASKED A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY IN THE BILL.
AND REALLY GOOD PUBLIC POLICY IS
NOT BEING CONDUCTED IN THAT AREA
RIGHT NOW.
AND I HOPE TO REVISIT THAT OKAY
SO THIS IS UNDER THE THE
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THE
LEGISLATURE THE THIS IS THE MOST
WE CAN GET FOR RIGHT NOW AND WE
SHOULD TAKE IT AND LIVE TO FIGHT
ANOTHER DAY THEN.
THIS IS A PIECE OF CRAP
SITUATION THAT WE CAN GET THIS
IN THE BILL AND WE'RE GONNA
REVISIT OKAY GREAT.
RIGHT [inaudible] FOR DIRECTLY.
I DIDN'T I DIDN'T KNOW THAT I
WAS JUST CURIOUS.
YOU GUYS WANT THE TRUTH.
OKAY WITH THAT -- AND HIS SOON
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE
THE THIS VOTE OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TODAY I THINK
VERY MUCH SENATORS.
THEY'RE NOT HERE FIVE CALDERON
PLEASE HERE.
SOME OF OUR CALDERON ARE YOU
READY ACTION MAKES [inaudible]
YEAH.
HOW YOU DOING THIS? EIGHT
BLOWING IT.
AB. FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX THERE IT
IS.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOW
ARE YOU MORNING THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
APPRECIATE THE TIME THIS BILL IS
REALLY SIMPLE TO ACTUALLY
MODELED AFTER A BILL THAT I DID
LAST YEAR WHEN HE CAME TO
CREATING WORKING GROUP. TO STUDY
BEST USES AND PRACTICES TO
IMPLEMENT BLOCKCHAIN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THE SAME THING WITH
ARTIFICIAL.
INTELLIGENCE BASICALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS CREATE A
WORKING GROUP TO UNDERSTAND THE
BEST USES AND PRACTICES WHEN IT
COMES -- TO FOSTERING INNOVATION
BUT THEN ALSO DEVELOPING
REGULATION ON THE STATE LEVEL TO
MANAGE -- THEY'RE VERY REAL
REALITY OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN THE IMPACT IT'S
HAVING ON OUR LIVES SO THE POINT
OF THIS BILL IS TO PUT THE
PEOPLE THAT KNOW.
ABOUT A I HAD THE PEOPLE THAT
KNOW ABOUT HOW. TO REGULATE
THINGS LIKE THIS TOGETHER SO
THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT ON A STATEWIDE
LEVEL WE CAN IMPLEMENT A THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD THEY WOULD
REPORT BACK TO US SO THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP REGULATIONS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PROPERLY --
REGULATING A AYE WHILE ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME CREATING A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FOSTER CREATIVITY
AND INNOVATION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE POINT OF IT I MEAN
QUITE HONESTLY THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS A LOT DIFFERENT
LEVELS ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
IT'S EXCITING THERE'S A LOT OF
GREAT THINGS FOR IN OUR LIVES
EVERYDAY LIVES BUT I THINK THAT
THERE'S JUST SOME THINGS THAT WE
DON'T THOROUGHLY UNDERSTAND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS IN DO
ANYTHING.
ABOUT IT SO BECAUSE WITH THE
TECH CAPITAL OF THE WORLD I
THINK IT'S REALLY COMING UPON US
TO DEVELOP THE MODEL REGULATION
WHEN IT COMES TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
NATIONWIDE BUT WE CAN DO RIGHT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I BUILT.
IN TASSIE ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION -- DO WE
HAVE WHAT SUPPORT A PLEASE THE
IDEA OF A TURN MEMBERS ALEX
TOURISM HAVE SPY METRICS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE SEVEN MEMBER WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT DO WE HAVE
QUESTION YES.
YES I JUST LIKE GARAGE LETTER ON
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A WAVE OF
OF THIS TAKING PLACE BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT THE EVOLUTION OF
TECHNOLOGY IS GETTING STRONGER
AND STRONGER.
AND IS IT DOES WE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO JUMP IN AND
TO REGULATE THINGS AND BE AWARE
OF THINGS. FOR THE FUTURE. TEN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW SO
I FIND THIS A A FANTASTIC BILL I
CONGRATULATE YOU I'D BE HONORED
TO BE A CO AUTHOR SO.
ABSOLUTE ROOM LET'S DO IT THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE OKAY SO WILL BE A
TAKING THIS UP SAYS WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU SO CENTERS
BRIDGET.
WE SEE FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
AB.
NINE ELEVEN DO WE DO WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE ELEVEN THIS MEASURE IS THE
FIRST STEP TOWARD ESTABLISHING A
SMART NINE ONE ONE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM WHICH WILL ENABLE PERSONS
TO VOLUNTARY SUBMIT BOTTLE
HEALTH INFORMATION. TO AVAILABLE
FIRST RESPONDERS CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WHO
ARE OLDER ADULTS OR PERSON WITH
MORE FULLY.
MOBILITY CENTRIC INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL AND OR MENTAL
HEALTH DISABILITIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE
CONSIDERED AT RISK HAVE UNIQUE
NEEDS AND RECTORY REQUIRE
SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS
ESPECIALLY DURING A CASE OF
EMERGENCY WORK THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO CLEARLY COMMUNICATE WITH
FIRST RESPONDERS.
IN ORDER TO BEST SERVE THESE AT
RISK INDIVIDUALS AND MINIMISE
ANY RISK OF INJURY IT IS
CRITICAL THAT OFFER FOR SPONSORS
FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT EMS.
BE PROVIDED WITH A PERSON VITAL
HEALTH INFORMATION PRIOR TO
ARRIVING ON SCENE.
HEALTH INFORMATION WOULD INCLUDE
KNOWN MEDICAL CONDITIONS
MEDICATIONS AN EMERGENCY
CONTACTS EACH BEING CRITICAL
PIECE OF INFORMATION FOR FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE A SYSTEM
THAT WILL HELP KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS SAFER
AND BETTER PREPARE FOR FIRST
PONDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WELL MORNING MISTER TEN MEMBERS
THANK YOU TERESA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION WERE
PROBLEMS CALL COSPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND AND IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'D LIKE TO DIFFERENT MY
TIME TO MY COLLEAGUES -- GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES AND AND
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD A COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ASTRAZENECA I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS ASKED ME LOCAL.
THIRTY NINE THIRTY WE REPRESENT
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
HOME CARE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO PROVIDE CARE.
FOR SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES MOST
VULNERABLE THE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I AM THE
MOTHER OF MANNY -- SO I AM.
ASKING FOR YOUR ALL'S I VOTE FOR
A. B. NINE ONE ONE THE MANNY
ALERT ACT -- AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
EXPLAIN TO YOU THE REASON WHY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT AND VITAL TO OUR
COMMUNITIES -- AS THE MOTHER OF
MANY HERE IS A TWENTY YEAR OLD
ADULT ARTISTIC -- HE IS VERY
MUCH MORE LIKE CHILD LIKE LIKE
THAT THAT OF A TWO YEAR OLD.
BUT HE IS NON VERBAL HERE'S
COMBATIVE HE'S A RUNNER.
HE IS ALSO ATHLETIC.
AND THESE ARE THINGS THAT I FEEL
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS TO KNOW IN
ADVANCE AND TO HAVE THAT
KNOWLEDGE WOULD BE ABLE TO MORE.
ADEQUATELY INTERACT WITH MY SON --
ALSO IN THE IT FOR INSTANCE IF
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO HAS
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA AND THEY
SPEAK SPANISH OR THEY HAVE PTSD
OR WHATEVER THE CASE IS -- YOU
WANT THE FIRST RESPONDERS TO NOW
YOU WANT THEM TO BE WELL
EQUIPPED SO THAT THEY CAN DO
THEIR JOBS EFFECTIVELY -- AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY EVERYBODY
GETS TO CALL HOME.
SO IN MY TRAVELS THROUGHOUT THE
LAST YEAR I HAVE FOUND SEVERAL
MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE STATE
FROM SAN DIEGO TO SANTA CLARITA
LA COUNTY HAS ISSUED A BE ON THE
BRING OUR LOVED ONES HOME -- ELK
GROVE AND KERN COUNTY HAVE A
SMART I WON ONE TYPE SYSTEM.
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR INFORMATION TO IN ADVANCE
AND FOR FIRST RESPONDERS HOWEVER
WE NEED SOMETHING THAT IS
COHESIVE ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THAT IF I GIVE MY AND MY
SON'S INFORMATION OR EVEN MY OWN
INFORMATION MODESTO CALIFORNIA
BUT I TAKEN TO DISNEYLAND AND HE
GOES MISSING.
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE I'M GOING BE
FRANTIC AND I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO REMEMBER EVERYTHING AND
THEY'LL HAVE A PITCHER AND IT
WILL BE IN REAL TIME.
AND IT WON'T BE LAGGED -- AND
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THAT WE THAT WE TAKE THE STEPS
INTO IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
EVERYBODY GETS HOME SAFELY TO
THEIR LOVED ONES AND WE LESSEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF ANY.
L. THINGS HAPPENING.
I THINK YOU AND I URGE FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU.
STEVEN WEBER OF CALIFORNIA ASKS
ME IN SUPPORT.
A WITNESSES OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE A QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS CENTER ON JULY OR
DETAILS SEVEN RUBIO DID YOU.
KNOW THAT YES I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WELL FIRST OF ALL.
A PLUS FOR CREATIVITY AB NINE
ONE ONE WHAT A GREAT WAY TO TO
REMEMBER THIS BILL RIGHT -- BUT
YOU KNOW I DO SEE THE IMPORTANCE
I JUST SAT WANT TO DO.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT BUT A
TUMMY THAT IT TALKS ABOUT A TIME
LINE AND HITTING A TARGET WHAT
IT IS THAT TIME NINETY LOOK LIKE
FOR YOU. TO BE THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS OF STRUCTURAL OF OUR NEXT
GENERATION ON NINE ONE ONE THIS
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL COMPONENT.
BUT REMEMBER THIS IS GONNA BE A
VOLUNTARY SYSTEM THAT YOU JUST
MORE INFORMATION LIKE I TALKED
ABOUT TO GIVE OUR FOR FISH
FINDERS PART ARRIVING ON SCENE
TO BETTER.
ESTABLISH THE TYPE OF PERSON
THEY'RE COMING ACROSS BECAUSE OF
THE DISABILITIES OUR HISTORY
THAT THEY HAVE SET THE TIMER
WORK WE CAL -- YES AS WELL TO
HELP BETTER SYSTEM I GET THE
SYSTEM GOING TO IMPLEMENT WITH
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ON
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE -- AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS MAKING
SURE THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE SHOW
UP TO A HOUSEHOLD AND NOT KNOW
WHAT.
THEY'RE DEALING WITH AND TELL
YOU CAN SAVE A COUPLE OF LIFE
THAT WE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
MEMBER CENTER ARCHULETA YES
THANK YOU -- THE BRIDGE BILL AND
I'M EAGER TO SUPPORT IT JUST A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS -- BACK IN
THE DAY WHEN EVERYONE HAD A
PHONE AT HOME I COULD SEE THE
NINE ONE ONE CALL COMING IN A
BECAUSE I WORK FOR POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND SO WHEN THE NINE ONE ONE
CALLS WITH COMMAND IT WOULD GIVE
THE ADDRESS AND SO ON SO NOW OF
I'M ASSUMING IN THE FUTURE IT
WOULD ALSO PRINT OUT FOR THE
DISPATCHER.
SOME OF THE DISABILITY TO WHAT
TO EXPECT -- BUT AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED YOU YOU HAVE TO CALL
IT IN.
SO ARE WE GONNA HAVE PEOPLE
CALLING NINE ONE ONE TO SAY BY
THE WAY I HAVE A CHILD EACH HAS
A PROBLEM RIGHT BUT AN ADULT TO
THIS OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE A
DISABILITY.
DOES THAT NOT TIE UP IN NINE ONE
ONE CALL OR DO THEY CALL THE THE
STATION ITSELF HOW DO WE GET
THAT ON THE SCREEN.
SO FOR INSTANCE I'LL -- THE
SMART I WON ONE OUTGROWTH IN
KERN COUNTY IS I'VE ACTUALLY
TOWARD THE FACILITIES AND I'VE
SEEN HOW IT WORKS.
THERE'S A NINE ONE ONE CALL THAT
PLACE FROM YOURS MULTIPLE
CELLPHONES THAT ONCE YOU'VE
CREATED THAT PROFILE IT
AUTOMATICALLY POPS UP ON THE
DISPATCHERS SCREEN.
WHICH THEN THE DISPATCHERS ABLE
TO SEND THAT INFORMATION OUT TO
WHICHEVER FIRST RESPONDERS ARE --
ARE RESPONDING TO THE CALL AND
THEN -- THAT SCREEN IS ONLY OPEN
FOR THIRTY MINUTES -- UNLESS
THERE'S A REQUEST TO KEEP IT
OPEN LONGER AND THEN THAT SCREEN
DISAPPEARS.
BUT THAT THAT'S KIND OF HOW IT
COMES IN THAT PERSON'S
INFORMATION PHOTO ALL OF THAT
COMES IMMEDIATELY ON TO THE
SCREEN FOR THE DISPATCHER AND
THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO COMBAT OUT
IN IN THAT KIND OF SYSTEM IF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS TO GO
WITH THAT KIND OF SYSTEM.
THAT'S HOW THAT WOULD WORK GOOD
BUT MIKE MY FOR THE QUESTION IS
WHEN YOU CALL WHO DO YOU CALL
YOU CALL YOUR LOCAL POLICE
STATION.
DO YOU DIAL 911-2 GIVEN THE
INFORMATION IT'S WHEN YOU MAKE A
NINE ONE ONE CALL.
AND IT GOES TO MAKE THE NINE ONE
ONE CALL TO GIVE THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU -- CREATE THE PROFILE
IN ADVANCE SO IT'S A PROACTIVE
VOLUNTARY -- YOU GO OUT AND YOU
CREATE YOUR PROFILE IN ADVANCE
INTO THE SNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT WHAT NUMBER DID YOU DIAL TO
GET.
THIS GIVES ME THE DETAILS ARE
GONNA BE DEVELOPED BY THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES OUT OF ALL
THOSE DETAILS THERE.
GOT IT GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
CAROL YES IN THAT ARE TRIGGERED
ON TO THE LOCAL LEVEL YEAH.
BUT AT THE END THE INFORMATION
IS THERE WE'RE SAVING A LIFE
WE'RE PREVENTING AN INJURY AND
WE'RE RESPONDING QUICKLY.
WITH THE PROPER MEDICAL TEAM --
OR SECURITY WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
[inaudible]
CENTER NIELSEN.
ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ MY
RELUCTANCE TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS
IS BORN OF THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WHEN WE'VE DEALT WITH THE
NINE ONE ONE LEGISLATION.
AND WE DID NOT PASSED LAST YEAR
BUT IT JUST HAS THIS YEAR.
AND THIS IS A BIT OF AN
EXPANSION ON THAT AND KNOWING
WHAT I KNOW ABOUT THE PLANS
WITHIN -- YES AND SUCH I'D
RATHER SEE THIS THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY EMPLOYED AND DEPLOYED
FIRST AND THEN TAKE THE NEXT
STEP AFTER THAT SO THAT'S WHY I
WOULD NOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EVEN GOT A THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO WITH THAT -- THERE'S NO MORE
QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE THE BILL
I TOO WAS IMPRESSED BY THE BILL
NUMBER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DID THAT
FREDDIE BUT ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE'LL
WE'LL TALK LATER -- SO WILL BE
VOTING ON THAT AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THE RESTAURANT IS AN ACTOR WHO
WAS HERE FIRST [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES.
I HEARD SHE WAS HERE FIRST IS
THAT NOT CORRECT [inaudible]
THERE IT [inaudible]
AND WHAT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
WILL IT BE OKAY IF WE TAKE UP AB
EIGHTEEN OH NINE FIRST.
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU LIKE TO DO
LET'S DO THAT ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS HI THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO THE D. B.
B. E. PROGRAM IN RESPONSE THE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT.
WHICH FOUND AMONG OTHER THINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS FAILED TO
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
AND RECORD KEEPING PROTOCOLS ON
CONTRACTS INVOLVING DVB EASE.
AB IN EIGHTEEN OH NINE ADDRESSES
THREE CORE ISSUES RAISED IN THE
AUDIENCE FIRST IT INCREASES THE
NUMBER D. B. B. EASE
PARTICIPATING IN THE STATE
CONTRACTING.
SECOND IT ENHANCES TRACKING AND
EVALUATION ABOUT REJECTED BODIES.
AND THIRD IT IMPROVES
TRANSPARENCY A PRIME CONTRACTOR
CERTIFICATIONS IDBS HAVE BEEN
PAID WITH ME TO TESTIFY OR
NUMBER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME A LOT OF
THEM TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
WE COULD BE GETTING.
HI I'M JACK SMITH I REPRESENT --
THE UNITED STATES VETERAN
BUSINESS ALLIANCE AS WELL AS MY
OWN -- PERSONAL BUSINESS I'M A
CERT DVB HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOURTEEN BUSINESS
MANAGEMENT CONSULTING -- I
REPRESENT SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT COMPANIES
THAT COMPETE EVERYDAY FOR
CONTRACTS HERE ANY BEEN
CALIFORNIA AND KEEP THAT MONEY
THIS CONTRACT DOLLARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS AS PART OF THE PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE TO BE HEADQUARTERED HERE
STAFF COMES FROM HERE -- THIS
BILL ALLOWS US TO COMPETE --
MORE EFFECTIVELY ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IS A SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE CAN'T COMPETE
WITH THE DILUTES THE CENTERS TO
THE BIG GUYS OF THE WORLD.
I THAT WHEN MOST OF THE
CONTRACTS -- MOVING THIS
CONTRACTOR VALUE FROM TO A FIFTY
THOUSAND TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WILL ALLOW US TO
COMPETE FOR MORE PRIME CONTRACTS --
THE WAY THE STATE BUNDLES THEM
TOGETHER NOW THEY DON'T WANT TO
AWARD A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT A COMPANY WHO'S DONE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS.
BUT IF THEY BROKE THAT CONTRACT
UP INTO TEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR CONTRACTS NOW WE
CAN COMPETE IN THE STATE CAN
ALSO WORE THOSE MORE EFFECTIVELY
IT'S A VERY LONG AND ARDUOUS
PROCESS TO REVIEW.
THE TWENTY FIVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSES TO OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PROJECT THIS HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PAGES OF OF RESPONSE.
AND SO THIS ALLOWS THE STATE TO
DO MORE EFFECTIVE BUSINESS AND
ALLOWS OUR BUSINESSES -- TO
COMPETE.
WE HAVE MORE THAN LESS THAN 40%
OF THE VISA COMPETE AT A PRIME
LEVEL TODAY -- BECAUSE THESE
RESTRICTIONS WE WE CAN'T MEET
THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND AND
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW US TO DO
THAT.
AND THE CAREER I'VE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AFFECT
VARGAS FOR THE UNITED STATES
VETERAN BUSINESS ALLIANCE WE ARE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
APPRECIATE -- THE TIME THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PUT AN
ESPECIALLY A TIP OF THE HAT TO
YOUR STAFF -- TONY SIMON'S --
ALSO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION -- WE'RE CONFIDENT
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO FIGURE
THINGS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR I'M FILL VERMEULE IN
REPRESENTING THE COALITION OF
SMALL AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES -- I'M HERE TODAY TO
TELL YOU THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF.
AND A WOMAN CAN GRADUATE CAN
GRADUALLY THEM AND THANK THEM --
I THINK WE'RE MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS SO FOR TODAY WE'RE
GOING -- TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE WORKING
IN GOOD FAITH WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL AND SEE
IF WE CAN CARP SOMETHING OUT I
THINK WE'RE MAKING VERY POSITIVE
STEPS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
AB ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES SEE
NONE.
IN CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
IN THE PRESENT IN THIS BILL I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL AND MOVE
IT -- OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY --
BUT I WILL TAKE A DEEPER LOOK.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT I
RESERVE THE RIGHT. TO PULL MY
VOTE FOR CHANGE MY VOTE EDIT
APPEARS TO THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE WHEN IT APPEARS TO ME --
I'M GLAD TO HEAR YOU'RE GETTING
TOGETHER AND MAYBE BY THE TIME
YOU FINISH.
THERE WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
TOTALLY PASSAGE WHEN HITS THE
VETERANS COMMITTEE.
BUT I JUST WANT YOU.
TO KNOW I'M AWARE OF THE
OPPOSITION YOU'VE AT WHERE THE
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE WORKING
NOW BUT TO YOU WORK THOSE OUT
AND BRING IT TOO MANY.
OF THEM WILL BE FULLY THUMBS UP
BUT FOR RIGHT NOW I'M OKAY LET'S
GO AND MOVE IT [inaudible]
THE DEALS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE THE BILL AS SOON AS
WE GET A QUORUM WILL BE VOTING
ON IT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR WE ALSO HAVE THE
NEXT ONE AB SIX THIRTY NINE ITEM
NUMBER.
SIX MISTER CHAIR IN SENATORS AT
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING TO A
LOWER CARBON ECONOMYINCLUDING
TRANSFORMING THE STATE'S GOODS
MOVEMENT SYSTEM.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
REMARKABLE PROGRESS PROGRESS ON
REDUCING HARMFUL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THE STATE HAS BILL TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THESE
ACTIONS ON CURRENT WORKERS?
AB SIX THREE NINE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
CONDUCTED IN THE GHG SCOPE
INCLINED TO IDENTIFY AND
RECOMMEND.
ACTIONS TO MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON INCUMBENT WORKERS IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS I WANTED THE
STATE'S MOST PRESSING NEEDS THIS
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A TASK
FORCE. TO ADVISE STATE AGENCIES
ON POLICIES AND FUNDING TO
MITIGATE THE EMPLOYMENT IMPACTS
OF TRANSITIONING SEAPORTS
OPERATION TWO ZERO AND NEAR ZERO
EMISSIONS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
DEVELOP AN EQUITABLE GAME PLAN
THAT SUPPORTS AN INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY AN UPWARD MOBILITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHILE ACHIEVING
LOWER GHG EMISSIONS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY'S
MARVIN BEING YETTA.
REPRESENTING I L. W. -- SUTURE
MEMBERS MARIN BMB HAVE
INTERNATIONAL LONG SURE WHERE
HOUSE UNION.
WE THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FOR AS
SOME OF YOU KNOW THAT IN THE
SENSE AS WE HAVE THE LARGEST ODD
TERM NOT PRATER ITEM MEETING I
PUTS FIVE HUNDRED WORKERS OUT OF
A JOB -- THAT ADAM MEDICALLY HAS
AN IMPACT IN THEIR SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES AS I A LOT OF OUR
I'LL W. MEMBERS WORK IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES SHOP IN THOSE.
COMMUNITIES BYE BYE REAL ESTATE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND WHAT WE
HAVE IS THAT PORTS ARE ON PUBLIC
LANDS PUBLIC LAND SHOULD BE HELD
FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS FORTY AUTOMATING.
THE PORTS MEANS THAT EIGHT SIDE.
IT'S OUR COMPANIES COULD
POTENTIALLY BE OPERATING
OPERATING OUR ARE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY [inaudible]
WHAT?
WHAT WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF IS
WHERE MIDDLE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE TRANSITION? TO TO CLEAN OUR
OUR ENVIRONMENT WE SUPPORT
CLEANER ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE WE
WORK AND LIVE IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE THINK WE
NEED TO GET THERE.
WE HAVE THE GOAL THAT ALL I HOPE
FOR EQUIPMENT BE XERNEAS YOUR
MISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY HOW WE
ARE PUSHING TOWARDS THAT WHAT WE
NEED IS WE NEED TO FIND A
BALANCE WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A
DETROIT AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ALL THIS POOR AREAS WHERE.
YOU HAVE NO AND POLICEMEN YOU
HAVE I RISING CRIME AND A LOT
ABOUT WHAT WILLHAPPEN IS A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO HAVE TO TURN TO
STATE.
SERVICES SO -- WE ASK FOR ENABLE
THIS BILL IS THE FIRST STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
SO THERE ARE TWO OUT OF THANK
YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
NIGHT TOTALLY SUPPORT THE
LONGSHOREMEN.
AND I'M SO GLAD EVERYONE
UNDERSTAND IT'S JUST NOT THE LOG
SHERMAN TO TEACHERS LABOR IS THE
ENTIRE AREA -- WHETHER BE LONG
BEACH LOS SANDERS WHATEVER IT IS
VITAL THAT WE COME TOGETHER --
TO TO SHAPEOUR FUTURE BECAUSE I
THINK THE TRANSITION -- FROM ONE
WORKFORCE INTO ANOTHER OVER
YEARS WOULD BE A GOOD THING AND
I APPLAUD THE LONGSHOREMEN FOR
COMING TOGETHER TO HELP CLEAN
THE SHOCKING ARE HERE AS WELL.
BUT THE THE ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT
IF WE IF WE DO IT TOO QUICKLY --
COULD HURT CHAU OVER A GOOD
NUMBER OF YEARS I THINK WOULD BE
A GOOD THING TO FOR THE
TRANSITION.
SO I APPLAUD OUR LONG SHERMAN
FOR COMING TOGETHER AND AND FIND
IN THIS RESOLUTION. TO TO TO
KEEP EVERYTHING MOVING ALONG BUT
DO IT CORRECTLY THAT MAKE SURE
OUR FAMILIES AND AND THE JOBS
ARE NOT IMPACT.
SO WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HAVING ONCE REPRESENTATIVE THE
PORTER SACRAMENTO.
AND HAVING THAT BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY I'M PRETTY CONVERSANT
WITH THESE ISSUES.
WE HAD SOME SIMILAR HOT.
WAY ACK IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES
WITH THE AIRPORT.
I THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT.
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND IN FACT.
THE TWO LITTLE KNOWN BUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
WHICH PASSED.
IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES.
DOES REQUIRE.
AN AGENCY IN PROMULGATING A
REGULATION TO CONSIDER THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
NOW FRANKLY OVER THE DECADES
AGENCIES HAVE PRETTY MUCH
IGNORED.
THAT PROVISION OF LAW.
BUT THIS HELPS ENSURE THAT IN
REGARDS AT LEAST IT TO OUR PORCH.
THAT THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
RESPECTED CONSIDERED TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT AND WAITED I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL.
SO WE WILL.
HAVE THAT MOTION THIS IS WE HAVE
A QUORUM.
AT EIGHT YES I WANT -- TO WE ARE
YOU DO ALL THE WITNESSES CARE
YES.
THAT ALL THE WITNESSES SO WE'RE
DONE SO SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM
WE WILL -- VOTE ON YOUR BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A
MEMBER.
AB FOR THIRTY SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY.
YEAH.
THE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE I NEED YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB FOR THIRTY SIX IS A
DISTRICT BILL.
IT ALLOWS THE HISTORIC NAPA
VALLEY OPERA HOUSE TO DEVELOP
ADVERTISING SPONSORSHIPS WITH
ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS INCLUDING
LOCAL WINE MAKERS.
THIS TIED HEALTH EXEMPTION CAN
ONLY BE USED IN CONNECTION WITH
SPECIFIC EVENTS FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE NONPROFIT.
OPERA HOUSE.
AB FOR THIRTY SIX WILL HELP THE
OPERA HOUSE INCREASE REVENUE AND
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THE OPERA
HOUSE MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO CONTINUE SERVING THE REGION
AS AN ARTISTIC AND CULTURAL HUB.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I WROTE
THIS AFTERNOON AND I HAVE WITH
ME A SUPPORTER.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF NAPA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN ARTICULATED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
KENNETH BODDY IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE I'M A CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL AND YOU ARE YOU TO GREAT
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND WE SHOULD AS WE HAVE.
WELL HOPEFULLY OU CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT LATER I'M NOT
SURE WHERE IT'S GOING AFTER.
SO WITH THAT -- AS SOON AS WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM WILL BE VOTING ON
YOUR BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CLUB I MAKE.
MAKE YES.
NO DOES REAL QUICKLY I'M GONNA
HAVE LIGHTS LEASING SO I KNOW
BECAUSE YOU CAN NEVER TOM
TALKING -- BUT I DO NOT IS GOING
TO SAY ARTS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND IT'S ONE OF MY I GUESS PET
PEEVES IN LIFE THAT WE JUST SEEM
TO BE HAVING LESS THAN US IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR OMMUNITIES AND
SO KEEPING SOMETHING LIKE THIS
TO LIVE IS VERY SIGNIFICANT SO.
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING.
THE ROOM MAY I BILLS AND I'VE
ALWAYS TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL I GO BACK.
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN
THE THE CITY WAS JUST TRYING TO
GET THIS OPERA HOUSE RE DONE.
AND WAS SO GLAD ALL THESE YEARS
LATER IT'S PROSPERED AND STILL
AROUND.
THANK YOU WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT -- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB.
FORTY ONE HOTEL BUT DOES GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE PROUD TO
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE AB
FORTY ONE WHICH REQUIRE THE
STATE.
HAD TO COVER THE LOCAL PORTION
OF THE CLEAN UP AND REPAIR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CAMPFIRE --
YOU KNOW AS YOU AS YOU KNOW AS
WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL -- THESE
FIRES HAVE BEEN. TO THE
DEVASTATING TO OUR COMMUNITIES --
RIGHT NOW.
AS WE SPEAK THE DEBRIS REMOVAL --
PROCESS IS GOING ON IN PARADISE
IN IN THE AFFECTED COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW IT IS.
THE IT'S BEEN A MONUMENTAL
EFFORT LARGEST -- DEBRIS CLEANUP
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY --
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
THAT HAVE BEEN DESTROYED -- IS
SO.
OBVIOUSLY THE THE SUPPORT THAT
WE CAN HELP GIVE THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY IS THEY'RE TRYING TO
RECOVER -- I WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
AND I THINK SOMETHING THAT IS
THAT IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT SIDE --
YOU KNOW JUST ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY ON THIS ON THIS
MEASURE AND WE DO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF MISTER YODER --
HALF OF BUTTE COUNTY -- THEN WE
ALSO HAVE -- KRISTIN CALL FIFTY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION.
MR MEMBERS POLIO HAVE THE BUTTE
COUNTY BOARDS TO RISERS JUST
THESE BECAUSE ON REIMBURSABLE
OVERWHELMED YOU COUNTY AND SO I
JUST WANNA THINK THE LEGISLATURE
THE NEWS MINISTRATION.
AND OBVIOUSLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER FOR JUST FOR
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY'S BEEN
DOING TO TRY TO HELP THE COUNTY
SURVIVE SO WE'RE DRY VOTE.
THANK YOU YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS
TO ASSIST THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE DEVASTATED BY THE RECENT
CAMPFIRE.
WE STAND WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OFFER CONTINUED
SUPPORT TO USE THE LESSONS
LEARNED BY THE TRAGEDY OF THE
CAMPFIRE TO BETTER MANAGER FORCE
[inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
WHEN THE BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE TO SIX
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL?
JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAMBERS MATTHEW SO I
REALLY HAVE BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY AUDITOR
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RUN EVERYTHING ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
STACEY HEATING THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE IN MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
WOULDN'T THINK SO.
THE MEMBERS WISHING TO COMMENT
CENTER NIELSEN.
THIS CHAIRMAN THE IN THIS VERY
ROOM A LITTLE OVER A WEEK AGO ON
A SUNDAY NIGHT THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WRAPPED UP ITS.
DELIBERATIONS FOR THIS YEAR.
AND I THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
SYMPATHY WITH THESE VARIOUS
FIRES THAT OCCURRED AROUND
CALIFORNIA.
IN PARTICULAR THE ONES IT
AFFECTED THE AREA THAT SOMEONE
GALLAGHER AND I REPRESENT.
MONEY IT WAS PUT INTO THE BUDGET
TO HELP OUT THIS IS ANOTHER VERY
CRITICAL PIECE OF THE LONG TERM
AND SHORT TERM.
GOAL I MEAN PROGRESS THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE. TO BRING BACK.
NOT JUST PARADISE AND THE RICH.
BUT ALL OF THE COUNTY.
AND IT IS A MODEL THAT WE'VE
EMPLOYED BEFORE TO HELP OTHER
COUNTIES.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE HERE AND
WHEN THE TIME COMES WE GET OUR
CORE MODEL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I TO THE I
THINK IS A GREAT DEAL THE
STARTED -- WHEN I WASN'T
ACTUALLY AND ASSEMBLY WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THIS FOR LIKE COUNTY
AND THEN?
THE FOUR FIVE COUNTIES WERE
INVOLVED IN THE NORTH BAY FIRES
IS CENTER NIELSEN -- RECALLS SO
ISSUES -- WE GET A QUORUM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WILL BE --
VOTING ON THIS.
BILL THANK YOU BUT JUST REAL
QUICK I WANT TO TASTE MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- MIA FOR YOUR WORK ON
GREAT WORK ON THIS ISSUE CENTER
NIELSEN AND I YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS IS PROBABLY BEEN
ARE.
OUR TOUGHEST CHALLENGE -- IN
DEALING WITH THE RECOVERY EFFORT
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU HAVE BEEN DOING AND AND
WORKING ON THE PATH FORWARD --
AS WELL -- THE GOOD NEWS IS OF
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
A GOOD PARTNER IN THIS TO NIGHT
BELIEVE THEY'RE NOW COVERING 90%.
OF THE COSTS DUE -- TO ME OU
REPRESENTATIVES CONGRESSMEN THE
MALL FOR A CONGRESSMAN THOMPSON --
WORKING TOGETHER -- SENATOR
FEINSTEIN ON THE SENATE SIDE SO --
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF GOOD
SUPPORT AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO A MEMBER
[inaudible]
OR IN PRESENTING A BILL IN G. H..
IT'S PRESENTED.
YEAH. SIXTEEN MEMBERS OF ONE THE
SWITCHES.
TAKE FOR EVERYTHING [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
QUESTION [inaudible]
SHE YOU -- NOTIFY.
MAYBE THIS WILL HEARINGS
[inaudible]
COURSE.
THIS IS A THIS IS A MANY MEMBERS
HASN'T DOWN.
WE'VE HAD FIFTEEN MEMBERS.
BUT LAST YEAR'S IT'S BEEN
THIRTIES.
OUR UP.
TO SIXTY IT'S ON THE BUILDING
[inaudible]
SHE WORKS.
STAFF THAT HE WAS ON OTHER --
YEAH [inaudible]
SHARE.
NOW THAT YOU'RE HERE WERE.
WE NEED FIVE MORE ONE OF THE
FORMER WORLD WAR.
THE FIRST MOVIE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY FOR THE NEW AGE --
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
IT'S QUITE GOOD.
LOCK THE DOORS OR ANYTHING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS LIKE THEY
USED TO SAY [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
IT WOULD.
THIS IS A NEW
.
I JUST SAW THAT.
GOOD MORNING WE GOT ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS A MEASURE WITH RESPECT
TO CLASS OR IN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
OKAY WITH THAT A WITNESSES WERE.
RESEARCHER MILLER -- MEMBERS
MELISSA AMALEK SING WITH AND HAS
A BUSH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY HELP US
GET THE APPROPRIATELY STYLED
GLASSWARE INTO THE MARKET PLACE
SO IF YOU ORDER A STOUT.
YOU'LL GET THAT BEER WITH A
STOUT GLASS A PILSNER WITH THE
PILLS ARE GLASS SIMILAR TO WHEN
YOU ORDER GLASSES CAMPAIGN NOW
YOU HAVE AN EXPECTATION FOR WHAT
THAT CLASS LOOKS LIKE THIS BILL
WILL HELP US.
CHANGE THAT EXPECTATION IN THIS
COUNTRY TO APPRECIATE YOUR ABOUT.
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THE BILL
ACTUALLY DOES -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION -- ONE
EIGHTY MEMBERS WISHING -- TO
SAILING SEE NONE.
SO THERE PORTANTINO DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF WASTE WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES GOING TO MAKE SURE HAT
EVERY CLASS IS THE APPROPRIATE
SIZE DOWN TO THE MILLIMETER.
NO I MEAN WE WE WOULD HAVE THE
BIG BOOTS YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE OUT
OCTOBER FASHION I DRINK OUT OF
THE BIG -- ITSELF.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT IS
THE IS THAT EMOTIONS AND OKAY.
YES I BUT WHEN YOU HIS ABS CORE
IT WILL DO THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THIS COULD.
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT.
AS A THIRD ONE OF THE SEVEN YOUR
FIRST TIME [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE YOU GOING [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THEY A GRAPH THAT.
THIS IS THE HEY THIS IS.
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION OUR
LAST FEW MINUTES BUT WE NEED.
SOMEBODY. FOUR FIVE SIX OKAY.
I MEAN I DON'T REALLY KNOW ONE
ANOTHER ALL [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE YES
A COPY [inaudible]
AND GEN.
WELL.
WE COULD HAVE A WONDERFUL IDEA.
IS A
IN A
DODD.
START HERE WELCOME.
ALLEN ARCHULETA.
ARTILLERY HERE PORCHES.
BRADFORD CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI HERE GLAZER
GLAZER HERE HILL YOUR BILL HERE
WHAT'S SO.
JONES NELSON.
NELSON HERE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE WINNER.
WE ARE HERE.
MR FROM THE CONSENT.
LET'S START FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND MOVED DOWN THE BUT
WE HAVE.
DODD OPEN THE MOTION.
THE MOTION THE MOTION I COULD
SET.
RUBIO.
I THOUGHT I'D WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHANGE.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO I WAS SO [inaudible]
JOHNS.
NIELSEN I'VE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THAT'S EIGHT HOLDING UP KATO
THEY'LL BE HELD OPEN ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE DIED IN.
TWO I WAS CONCERNED YES.
THE BILL.
WE NEED A MOTION ON ALL THESE
YES MOTION BY -- CENTER NIELSEN
A. B. FORTY ONE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM TO AB FORTY ONE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCH LETTER HIGH FORGES.
BRADFORD.
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL HILL AYE WESTERN
[inaudible]
JOHNS.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
HI. EIGHT EIGHT OH WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN -- WILL MOVE ON CALL --
WILL HOLD -- NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE A. B. FOR THIRTY SIX
A YOUR CURRENT MOTION
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
CENTER RUBIO FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY SIX MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
HI DODD I WILL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BRIDGES.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HILLS.
HELLO I WESTERN [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AY RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible] EIGHT
BOTH SETS ON CALL.
I DID SIX ITEM SIX AB.
SIX THIRTY NINE WE'VE GOT A
MOTION BY A SENATE ARCHULETA
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM SIX AB
SIX THREE NINE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD [inaudible]
DODD I ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'VE
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD.
CHANGE.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
JOHNS NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE EIGHT ZERO FROM COST
FEELS KEEP MOVING -- ITEM EIGHT
ITEM EIGHT AB NINE ELEVEN
RODRIGUEZ.
THE THE MOTION.
MOTION CENTER RUBIO CLASS ITEM
EIGHT AB NINE ELEVEN MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO ENERGY UTILITIES.
AND COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
DODD HI DODD AYE WILK HI.
WILK AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE FORGES.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL HI WES SO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO PORTANTINO.
TINA I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
HE WON IN WITH NINETY TO ONE
THAT'S ON CALL.
I AM NINE ITEM NINE AB NINE
SEVEN SIX CHAU.
THE MOTION MOTION SO MOVED SO
CENTER WILL CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
SIX MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DOT.
BY DODD AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCH LETTER AYE FORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HELL.
HELLO AYE WESSEL [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
SO THAT'S NINE SOME CALL THIS
NINE GOT NINE VOTES TOM CALL A
SITTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU BUT
BEFORE I'M NOT CALLING YOU UP
NOW I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW AS A COURTESY.
WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS WE GOTTA
GO TO OTHER COMMITTEE SO WE'RE
GONNA GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONCE.
THANK YOU WERE ALMOST.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
FILE ITEM. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE WE GOT A
MOTION BY CENTER RUBIO MOTION IS
THE ROSTER PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
HI DODD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL.
HELLO I WEST SO.
JOHN'S.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
THAT'S NINE NINE VOTES ON CALL
WILL MOVE NOW TO ITEM. SEVENTEEN
FOR ME SORRY.
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT SEVENTEEN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX CALDERON.
WHEN THE MOTION?
SIR ARCHULETA.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DODD HI DODD AYE WILK HI WILK
AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
HILL.
HELLO I WEST SO.
JONES.
NIELSEN THANK NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER I'D NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
TWO BILLS ON CALL.
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY LEVINE MOTION.
SO MOVED WILK.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD HI
DODD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
SALADA ARCHULETA I'VE GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL HILL AYE WESSELS
[inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN.
FIVE NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO THE TOP CALL AND
TWENTY AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
SAVANT.
THE MOTION FOR THAT.
OUR TO LET.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHILE ITEM
TWENTY AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
DODD HI DODD I WILL.
WILK HI ALLEN ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA AYE PORGES BRADFORD.
CHIANG GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
NINE ZERO ZERO THAT'S ON CALL.
REMEMBER TO AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY A BILL
THAT WOULD CREATE A NEW A. B. C.
LICENSE FOR THE UNIQUE SAINT
JOSEPH'S CHURCH IN MY DISTRICT
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
FIRST CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN
THIRTEEN THE SAINT JOSEPH'S
CHURCH WAS DESIGNATED A NATIONAL
HISTORIC LANDMARK AS WELL AS A
SAN FRANCISCO LANDMARK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY UNFORTUNATELY
NINE YEARS LATER AFTER
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE IN THE EIGHTY
NINE LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE THE
STRUCTURE WAS CLOSED.
THE CHURCH REOPENED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS A HOME FOR THE SAINT
JOSEPH'S PART SOCIETY.
A CULTURAL NONPROFIT INSTITUTION
DEDICATED TO CELEBRATING THE
ARTS DESIGN FOOD FASHION
LITERATURE AND PERFORMANCE.
THROUGH ITS FOUNDATION THE
CHURCH IS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AND
AVAILABLE TO ARTISTS AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO A. B. C.
LICENSE THAT EXIST THAT WOULD
PERMIT THE CHURCH TO HOLD THE
EVENTS THAT THEY'VE ENVISION.
ANY EVENT WHERE I'LL CALL SERVE
REPORT CHOIR A PARTNERSHIP WITH
ANOTHER EXISTING A. B. C.
LICENSEE.
THE PROCESS TO COMPLETE SUCH
PARTNERSHIPS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
IS ARDUOUS AND COMPLEX AND A
LIMIT ON THE NUMBER OF LICENSE
EVENTS SIGNIFICANTLY CONSTRAINS
THE FOUNDATIONS ABILITY. TO
SUPPORT ITS MISSION THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A NEW A. B. C.
LICENSE TO PROVIDE THE SALE OF
ALCOHOL DURING THE ARTISTIC AND
CULTURAL EVENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THE SAINT JOSEPH'S CHURCH.
TRULY BECOMES AN ASSET FOR
CALIFORNIA AND SAN FRANCISCO
ARTISTS AND COMMUNITY TO COME
TOGETHER WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO CALTRANS MOVABLE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF AN MEMBERS
KELLY JENSEN REPRESENTING THE
SAINT JOSEPH'S ARTS SOCIETY WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE A. B.
C. TO CONSTRUCT THIS BILL
SIMILAR TO OTHER -- MEASURES
THAT YOU PASSED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE THIS IS A AN AMAZING
FACILITY REPRESENTED BY -- BY
SIR WIENER AND THE AUTHOR AND WE
WE ASK FOR A YEAR A
CONSIDERATION NICE BIKE.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
BACK -- TO CENTER WIENER -- YES --
SO I UNDER THE BILL AND I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY -- THANK YOU
ALL TO BRING THIS FORWARD -- FOR
ANYONE WHO HASN'T SEEN -- THIS --
INSTITUTION THIS SITE YOU SHOULD
GO IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY AND UNIQUE AND
BEAUTIFUL -- PLACES AROUND IS
JUST AMAZING AND SO -- WHAT IF
YOU'RE IN SAN FRANCISCO CONTACT
YOU TO THE AUTHOR MYSELF AND
WILL?
OR HAPPY TO TO GET YOU THERE --
BUT I'LL BE COMING ON AS A CO
AUTHOR WITH THE NEXT ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS AND UNDER THE BILL.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION -- ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION -- CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
BY LATE IN FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN SEVENTY MOTION IS TO
PASS TO PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
DOT.
I THOUGHT I'D BALK ALL RIGHT
WELL I ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE PORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
CHANGE.
CHANGE HI GALGIANI.
JOHNNY AYE GLAZER.
HEALTH.
HELLO I WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THANK YOU CENTERS. NINE THE BILL
HAS NINE IT'S ON CALL.
LIKE TO WELCOMES SENATOR
BRADFORD TO THE PARTY TODAY.
BUDGET YOU BEING HERE.
SO WE'RE WAITING ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL.
YES WE GO THROUGH THE WORLD.
GOING TO STICK AROUND.
AMAZING LEVEL YEAH WELL
[inaudible] TO YEAH LET'S.
STARTED CONSENT ITEMS AND WORK
OUR WAY THROUGH THE WAS THERE.
IS OUT.
WHAT?
YOU DO CONSENT [inaudible]
AND THE SO THEY ARE ABLE RUN
SAID [inaudible]
WELCOME.
VETERAN YES ALL RIGHT OR IF YOU
BOTH ARE DOING IT WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO DO.
IT SURE AT YOUR PLEASURE
[inaudible]
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M -- PLEASE TODAY 2% -- A. B.
FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
CODIFY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AT RISK OF HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE.
THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF HATE GROUPS
HAVE MADE IMPROVING SECURITY AT
INSTITUTIONS SERVING FORMAL
COMMUNITIES IN URGENT PRIORITY.
THE DEVASTATING SHOOTING AT THE
WHOLE BODY PO WAY THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MASSACRED THE
TREE OF LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN
PITTSBURGH AND THE HORRIFIC
SHOOTING AT A MOSQUE IN NEW
ZEALAND.
ARE SOME OF THE LATEST EXAMPLES
OF HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE.
THE TO THE CENTER FOR THE STUDY
OF HATE EXTREMISM MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND JEWS WERE THE MOST
FREQUENT TARGETS OF HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS THIS
REST BY CODIFYING IN
STRENGTHENING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERED BY THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
GRANT FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR A
VARIETY OF SECURITY MEASURES
INCLUDED TARGET HARDENING AND
OTHER PHYSICAL SECURITY
ENHANCEMENTS SECURITY PERSONNEL
AND SECURITY TRAINING THAT WILL
HELP PREVENT AND MITIGATE
POTENTIAL ACTS OF HATE MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE.
MANY NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING HOUSES OF WORSHIP AND
COMMUNITY CENTERS OPERATE ON
EXTREMELY TIGHT BUDGETS AND ARE
UNABLE TO PAY FOR SUCH SECURITY
MEASURES.
THIS BILL WILL BE A BIG STEP FOR
TO PROTECTING COMMUNITIES
TARGETED BY HATE IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND PASSED THE
pBIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE MY
JOINT AUTHORED BY WANT TO THANK
AND ACKNOWLEDGE FOR HIS
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE SHOOTING AT THE
BOTTOM PART WAY.
AND FOR ALL HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE -- WALL LEGISLATIVE
ASSOCIATE FOR QUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND RABBI ARE YOU SU FRIEND HAD
OF SCHOOL AND YOU A BOYS HIGH
SCHOOL THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
TRANSFORMATION THANK YOU I
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE AT TODAY AS A
JOINT AUTHOR OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
EIGHT AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE HOW BOUT
OF POWER AWAY IN MY DISTRICT WAS
HIT WITH AN ACT OF HATRED.
AND VIOLENCE LAURIE GILBERT K.
WAS KILLED AND THREE OTHERS WERE
INJURED WHEN A GUNMAN OPENED
FIRE DURING SERVICES ON THE LAST
DAY OF PASSOVER.
THIS HATE FUELED INCIDENT AND
TOO MANY OTHERS LIKE IT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE LED TO AN
URGENT NEED TO IMPROVE SECURITY
AT RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS AND
OTHER NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDING
GRANTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AT A HIGH RISK OF
VIOLENT ATTACKS OR HATE CRIMES.
IN ORDER TO BETTER ENABLE THEM
TO EVALUATE AND UPGRADE THEIR
SECURITY AND SAFETY I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL --
AND GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON HIS ISSUE -- AS
WELL AS THE WITNESSES WE HAVE
HERE TO TO HELP WITH THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER TASK
WITNESSES SUPPORT [inaudible]
YES.
MORNING ON A BILL MEMBERS OF
GOVERNMENT OF THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ROB A ARE YOU SUFFERING AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT I
SERVE AS AN ACTIVIST FOR TEACH
CALIFORNIA AN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED. TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF SCHOOL CHILDREN.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IMPORTANTLY
THOUGH I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS THE HEAD OF SCHOOL OF YOU A
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND A PROUD FATHER OF FOUR
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN HAVE A GUY
WHO'S ELEVEN ELIANE WHOSE.
NINE SHOLOM WHO SIX AND ONLY AS.
FIVE EIGHT TO TEN JEWISH DAY
SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
IN MY DUAL ROLE AS THE HEAD OF
SCHOOL AND AS A PARENT.
I'M UNIQUELY AWARE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF SENDING OUR
CHILDREN TO JEWISH DAY SCHOOL TO
PRESERVE AN HONOR JEWISH CULTURE
AND TRADITION.
I'M ALSO UNIQUELY AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES OUR SCHOOLS FACE TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
FAITH BASED INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN SUBJECT TO INCREASE
SECURITY RISKS BUT AS YOU ARE
AWARE OF THE SITUATION AS
ESCALATED.
AND JEWISH INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF
THREATS OF VIOLENCE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
AS A PARENT IT IS UNNERVING TO
HAVE TO ANSWER YOUR CHILDREN
WHEN THEY ASKED WHERE SCHOOLS
NOT SAFE.
ADDITIONALLY AS THE HEAD OF
SCHOOL I GRAPPLE WITH THIS
QUESTION CONSTANTLY.
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES ARE
EXPENDED ON THE SECURITY EFFORTS
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE GOING
TOWARDS TEXTBOOKS TEACHERS AND
EDUCATING THE FUTURE LEADERS OF
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE LIVE IN A WORLD
OF TURMOIL WERE LOCKDOWN DRILLS
ARE NOW IS FREQUENT AS FIRE
DRILLS AND EARTHQUAKE DRILLS.
ALL OUR CHILDREN'S IN ALL OUR
SCHOOLS DESERVE A CHANCE TO
DEVELOP.
THEY DESERVE A CHANCE TO GROW
THEY DESERVE A CHANCE TO
INNOVATE TO LEARN AND STRIVE IN
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT A WORRY FREE
AND SECURE ENVIRONMENT.
AS CONFUCIUS FAMOUSLY SAYS IF
YOU WANT TO PLAN FOR A YEAR
PLANT RICE IF YOU WANT TO PLAN
FOR A DECADE PLANT TREES.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAN FOR CENTURY
EDUCATE YOUR CHILDREN.
ARE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY WILL HELP
US PLAN FIRST CENTURY ON BEHALF
OF MY OWN CHILDREN AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS LIKE
THEM I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION AND HELPING TO
KEEP THEM SAFE BY SUPPORTING A.
B..
FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF OUR ON BEHALF OF TO
TEACH CALIFORNIA THE ORTHODOX
UNION GROUP THE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WOULD JUST LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR THANKS TO THE JOINT
AUTHORS.
NESTOR I BOTH TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF
BURKE HEAR ME AFTER THE JEWS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE J. PACK
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS THE GOVERNOR FOR TAKING
LEADERSHIP IN FUNDING THIS
PROGRAM THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
SET UP CALIFORNIA CRITERIA AND
AUTHORIZE THE SOME FUNDS.
FOR THE USES THAT WERE NOT
CONTEMPLATED BY THE FEDERAL
CRITERIA ORIGINALLY -- WHICH WE
WORK WITH THE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS SO VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO
ENSURE THAT ARE THESE
COMMUNITIES.
HAVE THE SECURITY NEEDED TO
PROTECT.
THEIR PARTICIPANTS.
THANK YOU.
X. WITNESS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PRETTY -- WALL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA
WHICH FOR TWENTY YEARS NOW HAS
LED THE GOLDEN STATE'S FIGHT FOR
FULL LIVED LGBT Q. EQUALITY.
AS WE CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH WE
CANNOT FORGET THAT HE CRIMES AS
MENTIONED ARE INCREASING AT AN
ALARMING RATE THROUGHOUT THE
NATION AND IN CALIFORNIA.
NATIONAL COALITION OF ANTI
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS REPORTED THAT
AND 86% INCREASE AND HATE
VIOLENCE RELATED HOMICIDES OF
LGBTQ PEOPLE BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS ALSO THE
DEADLIEST YEAR ON RECORD. FOR
OUR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS RECEIVED
MANY A HATE MAIL DEATH THREATS
AND DIRECT THREATS BECAUSE OF
WHO WE ARE AND WHAT WE FIGHT FOR
AND THIS.
HINDERS OUR WORK BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO DIVERT TIME AND RESOURCES. TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF OUR
EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS HI OF THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY.
SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT OUR
EMPLOYEES AND CONTINUE OUR
CRITICAL WORK.
IN A SAFE AND SECURE MANNER MANY
LGBTQ PEOPLE DEPEND ON NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS BUT COMMUNITY
CENTERS SCHOOLS CLINICS AND
PLACES OF WORSHIP TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE RESOURCES ADVOCACY
AND A SAFE EVEN.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT WILL HELP
PROVIDE THE PROTECTIONS.
DOT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES NEED AND DESERVE SO
THAT CHILDREN CAN PLAY PEOPLE
CAN PRAY THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN LIVE FREELY IN THE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT THE WORRY OF
BEING TARGETED I TALKED WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
IN SUPPORT YES RIVER NOW ON THE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION FOR THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA OR
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IT WOULD ANY OTHER WITNESSES --
AND NOT ANY WEBSITE WITH THIS IS
OPPOSITION.
THIS -- WITH THAT -- CENTER
WIENER FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THANK THE THE AUTHORS
IN SPONSORING THIS FORWARD AND
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR THE
FOR THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR --
FOR WORKING WITH OUR CAUCUS IN
THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS.
FUNDED ON YOU KNOW I WILL SAY
THAT AS A AS AS A JEWISH PERSON
WHO SPENT A LOT OF MY CHILDHOOD
IN PARTICULAR -- IN A IN A
SYNAGOGUE AND COMMUNITY WORK --
JEWS ARE A TINY PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION THAT WAS -- IT
WAS -- A CITY SPACE FOR US.
SUMMARY JUST ASSUMED YOU GO AND
YOUR WITH YOUR COMMUNITY.
AND YOUR SAFE AND IS BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES AND THE
IDEA THAT -- ANYWHERE BUT
PARTICULARLY IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE -- A
SYNAGOGUE OR ANY PLACE OF
WORSHIP PEOPLE GOING IN AND THE
RELEASE ISSUED UP AND AND AND
ANSWERS MASSACRE PEOPLE IS JUST.
IT IS SO HORRIFIC AND AND OF
COURSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
PLACES OF WORSHIP WE KNOW THAT --
FOR EXAMPLE THE POLLS NIGHT CLUB
OUR FORTY NINE LGBT PEOPLE WERE
MASSACRED IN ONE FELL SWOOP AND
COMMUNITY CENTERS ARE RISKY AND
WE NEED TO DO MORE TO SUPPORT --
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS
NONPROFITS ENSURING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY IS SAFE AND SOME HAPPY
TO MOVE THIS BILL [inaudible]
NOBODY ELSE.
THANK KILL -- AYE RUBIO THANK
YOU I THINK THE AUTHOR OF ALSO
IS A MEMBER OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
AND WE'VE MADE AS A PRIORITY AND
AGAIN THINKING THE GOVERNOR
FIRST WORK BUT IT IS VITAL THAT
WE KEEP OUR FAMILY SAFE AND THIS
IS JUST AN IMPORTANT STEP IN.
AND HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE TO
TO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS AND WITH
THAT I ALSO ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU.
TERRIFIC DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OF THE BILL CENTER RUBIO.
IT'S GOT MAKE IT I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T CATCH THAT.
SO WE HAVE THE MOTION CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
BY GOD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES.
FORGES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
CHANGE CHIANG I'D GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GALGIANI AYE.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE WESTERN
[inaudible]
JOHN.
NIELSEN I NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE THAT'S TWELVE WILL ON
THE ROAD.
THAT'S TWELVE OLD ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE ARE GONNA -- I'M A CLOSE
THE ROLE AT ELEVEN AM.
SO WE GOT SEVEN MINUTES TO GET
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT NEED TO
ADD ON PLEASE LET'S START OF THE
CONSENT AND MOVE ON TOO LOW.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILK.
HI WILL AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
GORGEOUS. FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGED.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES. THIRTEEN AND AS THIRTEEN
VOTES SONG CALL.
FILE ITEM TO A. B. FORTY ONE
MOTION IS YOU HAVE TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
VOTE EIGHT ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILK HI.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE CHIANG I'D
GLAZER.
GLAZER I'D PUESTO [inaudible]
JONES HI [inaudible]
JONES. FIVE FOURTEEN ZERO PULLED
IT OPEN.
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
WILK HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
GORGEOUS FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE CHANGE I
GLAZER GLAZER AYE WEST SO.
JONES [inaudible]
JOHNS I OPEN.
FORTY ZERO FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY
SIX THIRTY NINE MOTION AS YOU
PASS THROUGH PERFORATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS WILK.
HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
HI GLAZER.
PLEASE OUR EYES WESTELL.
JONES [inaudible]
JONES I NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
NINE ELEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO ENERGY UTILITIES
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT TO ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE WEST SO.
WEST SO I JONES.
JOHNS I THIRTEEN THIRTEEN A ONE
BALANCE OUT. THIRTY ONE THAT WAS
OUT I WOULD LIKE -- TO WELCOME.
CENTER HUESO TO THE PARTY AS
WELL.
THAT ONE'S ON CALL FOR ALLEN.
SORRY TO MY RIGHT.
YOU WANT TO BE WELCOMED.
SO -- JOBS I WELCOME YOU
WHOLEHEARTEDLY TO THIS PARTY.
THAT WAS ON CONFERENCE CENTER
CHIANG.
WELL FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN SIX MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHANGE I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI.
GLAZER AYE WESO.
Y. SO I'D JONES.
JONES I SO FIFTEEN FOR HOLDING
IT OPEN.
FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE MOTIONS YOU PASSED
YOU APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS I BRADFORD ON
BRADFORD I CHANGED CHIANG AYE
GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE I REQUEST SO WITH SO
I JONES.
JONES I FIFTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY
MOTIONS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE YEAH
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE.
GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER.
LASER I WAS SO.
WITH SO I JONES.
I SIXTEEN ZERO THAT RUNS OUT
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT ONCE CLOSED
OUT.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO.
WITH SO I JONES [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO. FIFTEEN ZERO THAT
SONG COSTS ARE CALL.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX MOTION IS PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CURRENT BEAU
IS NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES OR JUST AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CHAIN.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE WEST SO.
WITH SO I JONES.
JONES I SIXTEEN ZERO MOUNTAINS
OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY MOTIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VO IS NINE
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE PORGES.
OR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CHANG CHANG HI
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WEST SO.
WEST SO I JONES.
JONES EYES SIXTEEN ZERO BALANCE
OUT.
FILE ITEM -- TWENTY MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO VETERAN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
YEAH BUT I ALLEN I FORGES. FOR
JUST AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CHIANG CHING AYE
GLAZER [inaudible]
YEAH.
GLAZER.
WEST GLAZER AYE WEST SO IF WEST
SO I'D KNOWN.
JONES EYES AT SIXTEEN ZERO THAT
ONE IS OUT.
OKAY SO NOW.
GET THIS BEING THAT I SET A
PRECEDENT I WHAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN FOR ACTUALLY
SHOWING UP -- TO THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IN AS SUCH -- THE LAST
COUPLE COPY AND IN THE MACHINES
FOR UV [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH.
THERE'S THIS IS AS GOOD NATURIST
SO.
BUT EVERYTHING ELSE IS.
IF YOU DO MAKE SENSE.
SO WE'LL JUST GO.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ONES THAT ARE.
OUT [inaudible]
YEAH.
CONSENT COUNTER ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN I'D.
ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN HI WES SO.
WITH SO I SIXTEEN ZERO THAT'S
OUT.
FILE ITEM SIX MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I FORGES.
WEST SO.
WITH SO I FIFTEEN ZERO OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE ELEVEN
MOTION IS TO PASS TO ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I GORGEOUS.
AND THANKS BILL [inaudible]
YEAH. FOURTEEN THE ONE THAT'S
OUT.
FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY SIX MOTIONS YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I SIXTEEN ZERO OUT.
FILE ITEM TEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I SIXTEEN ZERO THAT'S OUT.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE.
ABSENT MEMBERS PORTANTINO.
AND FIFTEEN ZERO OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THIS MEETING OUT
AT THIS POINT TIME THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
COMMITTEE IT'S NOW ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
RIGHT